[Music]
this woman caught on camera she's
accused of seducing and stealing from a
man
she just met and police say she did it
by drugging her victim our janiece
stanwood spoke with him and she joins us
live from hollywood with what that man
had to say janine
louie lori we have heard this story
before that man tells us that the date
was going well but then when he brought
her back to his condo here in hollywood
that's when he said things went south
i'm not ugly i
i date frequently he doesn't want to
show his face or use his last name but
michael is mad because he says this
mysterious brunette in the sultry crop
top not only played him but also drugged
him and stole from him you guys do the
most you guys do the most in this sultry
it's a crop top
it's not it's just boobs and we see her
belly
you guys do the most can i appreciate
he didn't want to show his face these
knees did not give one single [ __ ]
and they're like so you want to be
anonymous
all right well
jay williams age 43 living out hollywood
13 44.
dock that [ __ ] with the whole
building in his face yes about 11
o'clock i meet this very nice lady about
30 years old it was november 19th
michael says the night began at the hip
kiki on the river in miami we got along
i bought her a drink followed by
cocktails at scarlet's cabaret in
hallandale beach but when he invited her
back to his place in hollywood and here
they are walking down the hall that's
where he says the problems begin we had
our interlude within about 15 minutes of
opening up a bottle of nice puddle of
champagne i was asleep police say
michael involuntarily consumed a
substance which rendered him unconscious
next thing he knows it's after 9 a.m the
next day the woman seen here leaving
with a big blue bag is gone and so is
all his pricey stuff they had a brand
new tiffany watch as well as a cartier
watch a tiffany ring like this and cash
were you embarrassed yeah of course i'm
very embarrassed embarrassment aside he
calls police that's him we showed the
mystery lady's photo to the manager of
scarlett's who tells us he'll keep an
eye out who that girl
hey she look good fat booty on her
yeah
i look out for her
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you think you got it and all is
well and you're being cool
guess what buddy check check and recheck
men look
you're just as vulnerable as a woman
and michael says he believes that that
woman's name is katrina and she thought
she stole your [ __ ] you think you think
she gave you the ah brub
rookies [ __ ] rookies hey man and much
like katrina she came in like a
hurricane yo [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah hey man
she came in like a tsunami [ __ ] she
took up everything mommy alert
she took up every you thought you won't
get the tsunami alert down there she's
doing a tsunami of learning your
apartment [ __ ] she took everything all
your [ __ ] tsunami alert no you're not
getting your dick sucks yo she's just
getting your stuff sucked okay hey
listen man
cardi b that's the real she got cardi b
that's the real [ __ ] he said you know he
said listen man you guys are just
vulnerable and it's true
hey man i said this in the last video
and i'll say it again i'm too ugly for
this [ __ ] girl trying to come back with
my place the first time i'm like um no
it's not real
that's us have you approached me
that's us and we've seen and we've seen
you we've seen you dude because they
they [ __ ] doc out of you and you said
i don't look that bad for your age
you don't look that bad for your age
and even then ui if it happens too
quickly
that's the bet one of the best bars you
said
if she comes and she's like oh papi
you can papi your way over there yeah
cause
that's way too easy yeah yeah yeah do
evie the [ __ ] you want yeah if she
coming out too quick you're probably
gonna leave in a buick
it's not gonna be good and you also have
to remember you're in miami
coming come on now
okay
they are they love skating [ __ ] out
there okay
so
you know what i'm saying is she coming
up on you right
she looking fresh and fit
don't fall for it
guys need to learn this guys need to
learn this because sometimes
it seems so good to be true you just you
can't wait the thing is and you got dick
goggles on so you can't even tell right
he pulled out the glass of champagne so
he never even saw her slip it into his
drink
which means that she has some next level
game where she's probably like hey can
you get me some ice and she just slipped
it in real quick easy peasy lemon
squeezy
so
you guys
all this to say in this case it's lemon
snoozy
today's video is brought to you by
sandberg what is sandberg well it's a
fragrant subscription service it
basically gives you access to 600 brands
of fragrances you know sometimes you
don't know which one to choose and you
want to see what's out there you want to
try out stuff become these really cool
cylinders that are super easy to use you
just pop it up here boom that's it soup
super easy to use okay and you can use
it for 30 days try it out and if you
like it then you can commit rather than
paying hundreds of dollars for a
fragrance that you may not even like
long term this gives you a chance to
actually rock it wear it see how you
feel with it you choose what you want
you choose if you want a 3 6 or 12 month
subscription and then boom at your door
you get your fragrance and they have
high-end brands like prada gucci versace
as well as a variety of high-end
fragrances that you can choose from and
right now you can use my promo coupon i
might preach two to get 30 off your
first month on scent bird that's 11 for
your first month to get your fragrance
why not treat yourself okay and here's
the truth
at the end of the day she's always the
evil doer right she's the one who did
wrong she scammed this man she should be
in jail we all agree what can you guys
do to protect yourself all right now i
don't think it's reasonable enough for
me to say don't do any one-night stance
because [ __ ] get horny it is
what it is all right
but what i would say is
just be careful
you know i mean every time you invite a
random person that you just met into
your home you add those risks remember
that story from australia
from that guy who went on a tinder date
with a girl brought her back she fell
off the balcony and died yet a murder
charge
right like things can escalate so fast
real quick very fast real quick and i
want you guys to be able to protect
yourselves in that regard so you know be
mindful that if you're gonna do this and
you're gonna bring strangers into your
home the odds of you getting robbed rise
exponentially the odds of you getting
much worse rise exponentially right
and so just be mindful of that when
you're going out there
however you got to do it just be careful
i guess is what i would say and also
when it comes to drinks
just don't be open to taking drinks from
random people especially if they're
trying to get you home funny thing is
they talk about oh you're asked
vulnerable as a woman but the funny
thing is it's actually his privilege
that got him in a situation him thinking
that he was you know he he's the hot
[ __ ] he's the hot [ __ ] and he's
and he's stronger so nothing can happen
nothing can possibly happen to me
sometimes having that kind of privilege
puts your guard down it lowers your
guard down and then boom
that's how they snuff you
and he got snuffed that's how you get
caught slipping oh it's lit to nine in
the morning
yeah and you know one of the worst parts
about red rod like that is it really
does traumatize you
it really clouds and it
muddies the way you experience things
afterwards you know after i had my spot
broken into bro like [ __ ] i got a knife
beside my bed at all times i always have
a weapon i'm good like i'm not good in
the sense but i'm ready in case it
happens but it made me feel like i
remember for a couple weeks man it was
hard to sleep in my place definitely you
know i i triple locked everything i was
on my roommate's case about always
everything locked and just making sure
everything's safe it's like whoa
somebody was in my space but somebody
steals your [ __ ] like it's also very
emasculating you had somebody steal your
prized possessions
that leaves you with a lot of anger
right
because you want to get back at the
people who wronged you
so the after effects of getting robbed
like that really linger as well any time
beautiful women come on too strong i'm
not saying you gotta like [ __ ] [ __ ]
get away from me you know you have to go
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] you want to rob
don't go nuts don't lose your mind okay
but
if she's pushing why are you pushing so
hard yeah man it's not normal for him to
be pushing this heart this aggressive
way unless you're like really attractive
then like this video is not for you you
got it you can unsubscribe nobody's
talking to you but two ugly [ __ ] okay
because most y'all who are watching are
ugly yeah
be suspicious
we've seen you
i mean [ __ ] i got this youtube channel
i'm still suspicious of everybody who
talks about that
i'm more suspicious now yeah definitely
yeah be scrutinize these people
all right because [ __ ] will try
to finesse you promise you especially if
you look like you got some bread you go
to high-end spots which is what this guy
did they will try to finesse you so just
be careful and take care of yourselves
haven't you seen anything as a balancer
yeah definitely yeah i've seen that i've
seen that
i've seen that
but it's really that it's really the
same thing it's nothing much more to
have people you know you see them leave
together next time he comes back because
he try to find a girl and see the girl
if the girl is going to be there you
know yeah yeah most of the guys yeah
most of the guys whenever they get
finesse like that they come back to the
spot because they want to you know like
that guy that lost his phone in the
middle
they come back to the bar to see if the
girl hangs around there or whatever what
the hitters the hitters
they hit one spot and they don't try to
come back to that spot and miami has a
lot of spots
so
if you look good or you're attractive
people are gonna notice you you cannot
be a regular people that hit you like
that they're not regulars and you see
people get movies right
yeah i've seen that
guys girls yeah i've seen that i
definitely see that mm-hmm
yeah you got to act you got to do
something if the girl leaves and she you
have to ask questions basically ask a
question
you trying to kind of ask questions to
the girl what's up this and that and i i
try to i ask them to do [ __ ] oh uh
you drop your phone yeah you drop your
phone again you drop and if i see that
you're not responsible you always go
down or everything that i tell you hey
can you go to the left right quick go to
the right i back it up i bring him up
one time you go to the front and she
does everything so basically yeah it
sounds like i'm playing games with a
girl but
uh it's really to see if she does
everything that i say without
questioning it it's really a sign of uh
gh ghb right it's really a sound of that
so it makes you very agreeable you just
follow people and that's why it's easy
to take advantage of of that but other
than that i used i used to to i used to
be very careful about that because
depending on where you are a bouncer uh
what what city
uh what state what province you are
bouncer at if something happens bad to
your patrons you're gonna be held the
car the owner is gonna yeah you're gonna
be liable for what happened so let's say
someone leave a bar
depending where you're at sometimes once
a patron leaves the bar drunk
you had security there he took his car
and then you didn't do nothing about
that you could be held responsible if
there's damages or people that die
that's why
that's why we cut people off that's why
we cut people off for the safety of the
people for the safety of other people
because like we don't know you're gonna
be like no no i'm walking and you're
fully i can't check i can't
search you i'm not the cops so i can't
physically search for your keys or
whatever or not no no i'm walking but
this motherfucker's gonna walk off to
his car i don't know that but if i
served him that many drinks i should
have known and i should do better so i
gotta i gotta take i gotta take that in
accountability you know the drugs this
and that but it's something that happens
you got money you got alcohol you got
humans there's about to be dumb [ __ ] and
that's why we did what we did you know
but but yeah people get roofied
oh yeah yeah yeah unfortunately it was
uh it really was a thing you know we
have
codes sometimes sometimes you're gonna
go to a bar and they're in in the ladies
room there's some codes if you uh for
example if you a if you order a blue
angel at a bar
like she goes to the bar she orders a
blue angel we
uh escort out back we call you a cab and
you're both about to leave if you order
a blue angel with ice we call the cops
yeah i mean so there's cause the girl
is it's like whenever you call 9-1-1 and
you're an abusive relationship if you
call 9-1-1 and you order a pizza
it's like 9-0-1 can get what's your uh
9-1-1 what's going on uh yeah i'd like
to order a um large boring pizza is the
person over there yes
is it is easy being violent say with
cheese uh yeah with cheese or no cheat
you know what i mean if you or if you
call that so so bars have some kind of
things like that wherever ladies some
bars whenever they order a special drink
it's a drink it looks like a drink a
blue angel can sign like a drink it
could be any kind of drink but it's a
it's it's uh it's
it's a code there's a code usually it's
a woman installed you're saying this
right now
someone at home is going to watch this
and go to a bar with her abusive
boyfriend and go to the bartender and be
like can i get a blue angel and the
guy's like yeah sure
it depends of the bars usually it's
in the in the the ladies room dakota's
in the ladies room
so so yeah but yeah yeah yeah there's
stuff like that you know you try to make
the environment safe try to make you
know
even try to make it enjoyable for
everybody so you got to watch out for
your people that are annoying
ladies i've ladies that are annoying and
men that are annoying both they they get
the same treatment for me so if you
[ __ ] you know you're [ __ ] up you're
being disrespectful you're getting
tossed out but i gotta i gotta admit
when i'm physical i'm i've been more
physical with women than men but men is
more violent it's more efficient but
girls
they know they can't hit you so they'll
they'll wail on you
out